I highly suggest that you watch this
video before you eat another egg there
is a huge difference between the
conventional eggs that you get at the
grocery store versus something that is
called pastard raised organic eggs
there's a huge difference and that's
what I'm going to get in today
unfortunately even the expiration date
is not regulated so in other words
companies can just omit that that little
date on the box and it's not unlikely
that these eggs could sit on the shelf
for 60 days that's two months before you
end up buying them but one of the things
that really shocked me when I did a deep
dive in this topic
is the feeds that they feed the chickens
the animal feeds okay what are in these
animal feeds yes they have GMO corn and
soy and that's very unnatural because
these chickens Were Meant to consume
bugs insects worms flowers seeds things
like that but I found out that there's
another ingredient called animal
by-products or another name for that
would be animal protein products that
would include
the carcass of another animal
feathers organs blood skin even of the
same species and manure and at first I'm
like wait a second that can't be true
but as I dug further into this topic
it's true these animals are fed now
of course you also get an option on the
label sometimes they're fed vegetarian
feeds right well I want to bring up a
point about vegetarian feeds and that
would be corn and soy no animal products
okay but I also want to point out that
it's very unnatural for a chicken just
to consume grains without bugs worms
things like that which by the way are
not vegan and chickens are actually
omnivores so that leads me to the next
topic about eggs relating to the color
of the egg yolk some people had this
idea that if you look at the color of
the egg it'll tell you the health of
that egg right makes total sense until
you find out that they actually sell and
use on a regular basis
colored pigments synthetic dyes to make
the yolk look a certain color because if
you don't do that the consumer is not
going to buy it so honestly this is just
a way of tricking the consumer the name
of one of the dyes is called can't the
xanthins and at least in Europe they
restricted this to a certain amount
because they found it causes crystals
that develop on the retina now as far as
in America I have no idea but in nature
when you have a natural chicken that
consumes what it's supposed to eat
you get a really nice gold yellow color
of that yolk that is all the natural
antioxidants especially the two
nutrients called lutein as well as Zia
xanthin which are all necessary for your
eye for the retina and so an egg that
has less of this Rich pigment the less
of those antioxidants you're going to
have and there's not just those two I
mean there's probably over 600 different
carotenoids they use dyes also to color
the meat of the chicken to make sure it
looks like a healthy chicken skin I mean
it's just crazy what's happening even if
you go to the grocery store and you buy
a chicken breast right just look on the
back of a label you'll see that in some
cases they add flavoring I'm not kidding
to make it taste like chicken
so basically we're tricking people into
making it taste good look good without
really focusing on the quality now I've
talked about the chicken feed a little
bit but what about the environment the
space right you have different terms
they throw around like free range and
cage-free and pasture-raised the first
thing you need to know is that
conventional chickens are in cages and
they never see the light of day and
you're talking about probably roughly
having up to 80 to 100
000 of these chickens in one Barn in one
space and it's also been studied that
the cortisol greatly spikes in that
situation that can't be healthy for the
chicken and then we have something
called cage free it sounds a lot better
but all they do is they remove the cage
but they don't change the spacing so in
order to be cage free you actually have
to have a foot of space for that chicken
so you're still shoulder to shoulder
you're still in a closed space then you
have free range right what does free
range mean well for free range you get
about two uh square feet of space you
have some limited outdoor access there
might be a hole in the barn where uh it
can stick its head out to maybe see
outside and if I'm not mistaken free
range is um antibiotic free whereas cage
free they can use antibiotics like
conventional and then we get to pasture
Rays this is the best because they get
108 square feet of space per chicken
much better and they are allowed to go
out in forage for bugs and worms and
insects and flowers and things like that
and if you if you compare pasture raised
to Conventional there is at least three
times as much vitamin A retinol there's
more choline there's more B2 there's
more folate there's three times as much
vitamin E and overall you're going to
get more fat soluble vitamins now I do
want to mention antibiotics for a second
because you might say well they don't
really use antibiotics anymore well
worldwide out of all the cell of
antibiotics 66 of all of those
antibiotic cells are sold to farm
animals and in America eighty percent of
all antibiotics are used for farm
animals so of course when you get eggs
when you buy eggs make sure it says
antibiotic free or even better yet just
do organic
pastored raised eggs that way you
include a better environment for that
chicken as well as a better source of
feed because organic has to come without
those pesticides insecticides herbicides
non-GMO which is good but they also have
no hormones no antibiotics no Arsenic
and no poultry Slaughter
byproducts so in other words those
animal byproducts that include the waste
are not in organic now you might say
well they're more expensive yeah they're
a few more dollars well guess what it's
worth it and even the reason why they
use antibiotics they use it as a growth
hormone that's what they're using to
grow them in a very fast rate now I was
driving down the freeway a while ago
maybe three weeks ago and I got behind
a huge tractor trailer filled with
chickens and cages
and I had to really make sure that I
kept my eyes on the road because I was
looking at these chickens just terrible
terrible terrible situation because
these chickens did not look healthy at
all and they were in complete Terror one
last thing about these chicken eggs
sometimes you'll see omega-3 enriched
okay and that is a marketing gimmick you
don't really know the source of Omega-3
that they're enriching these chickens
with personally I think you'd be better
off just focusing on the pastured raised
organic chicken eggs or better yet if
you have the space for them and you can
put chickens in your backyard I would
highly recommend to do that when people
come over to my house and they stay over
and I feed them the eggs wow it's
incredible they just they're like wow
these are so satisfying they're so
delicious they're amazing uh so I highly
recommend you think about maybe getting
your own chickens so now that you know a
bit more on differentiating the type of
egg that you really need let's talk
about some other benefits of the egg
from this video right here